so after the coronation of course you
have the celebrations across the country
and here in Walking Bay they are trying
to set a record for the most attendees
ever at a street party they're hoping
for 10 000 people to come here and
they're starting to get ready for the
event if you could take a look around
we've got the beautiful Seaside and
there are a couple of people who are
taking a dip that's a jubilee swim I'm
not quite bold enough to go in there
it's extremely cold but they've decided
to do that as a way of mocking marking
the uh the coronation out there and then
we've got some of the tables there are
going to be hundreds of tables lined up
along the Promenade this is one that's
laid out quite intricately here you've
got a couple of of mugs a little couple
of Cups you've got the uh the the
British flag on the table as well that's
the sort of thing people have been
organizing and getting ready and I think
we can talk to one of the organizers of
the event she's uh she's on the phone
she she oh well we'll try something
we'll try someone else we'll try we'll
try the Haitian flower file who you've
dressed up for the occasion how are you
feeling ahead of what's meant to be a
massive event hopefully it's going to be
a success the sun's come out for us
which is really really great really
fantastic and we're here promoting
Haitian flower Pie as you can see
entering in Britain In Bloom so we'll
hope to go put the grape back in Great
Britain now to get the best in Great
Britain for our small village I'm very
much enjoying your uh your costume here
it's very fluorescent absolutely you
have to you have to do something special
especially when we've got a new King on
the throne you've got to put thumbs up
for that new Venture for us all
right Kerry Matthews who is the chair
and welcome council is also now free I
know that you're super busy so thank you
very much for talking to me just tell us
a bit about what you're attempting to do
with this event today we're attempting
well we are going to break our own world
record so we're expecting over 10 000
people here at the event
um it's already starting to fill up
there's already a vibrancy as you can
see there's a mile long parade coming
along at half past one
and tell us a bit about why it's so
important to get the community together
off the back of a historic event like
yesterday well it's all about the
community isn't it you know our King is
very Community focused and and this is
just a way of us celebrating not just
our King and his coronation but us our
town are more come Our Town Council
everything that we do together to make
more from a wonderful place for visitors
and the community and after slightly
overcast guys it looks like the weather
is going to be kind to us I hope so I
think so it's starting to warm up isn't
it my fingers aren't quite as cold as
half past seven this morning but yes I
believe that it's going to it's going to
brighten up and our swimmers are out in
the bay the Mallows yeah we spotted them
that's uh pretty bold yes
they're very sturdy winter
organizing this very grateful for your
time so that's the scene here and I
think you get the sense that off the
back of the coronation now is a chance
for people to come together in their
communities and celebrate in their own
unique ways one of which will be
thousands of tables lined up on the
Promenade here starting at one o'clock
today
o'clock today